we're going to begin with this the
newest coronavirus outbreak could reach
its peak at the same time
that president-elect biden is sworn in
that's according to one former fda
commissioner
mr biden calls this pandemic one of the
most important battles he will face
yesterday he and vice president-elect
kambla harris
announced a 13-member covet advisory
board to prepare his administration's
response
the president-elect vowed to follow the
science and urged americans to put aside
political differences and please
wear a mask the goal of mask wearing
is not to make your life less
comfortable is to take something
or take something away from you is to
give
something back to all of us a normal
life
the goal is to get back to normal as
fast as possible
joining us now is a member of the
president-elect advisory board that's
michael ulster home he's director of the
center for infectious disease research
and policy
at the university of minnesota good to
see you mr ulster home a lot of people
were excited to hear you were on the
board because
you're known as a straight shooter who
pulls no punches
people think you're a great addition so
thank you for taking the time
thank you what's the advice what's the
advisory board's goal at this particular
moment
well obviously it just formed yesterday
yeah and so we're still working that out
but
i'm very encouraged that president-elect
biden
and vice president-elect harris are
really looking at the
really critical issues around how do we
stop this virus now what can we do
how do we make the transition to
vaccines and so i
i think that the uh it's going to offer
a lot of
good information for how cities states
and counties can really
move forward on their own without any
other federal leadership
are you encouraged that are you
encouraged that they said
up front they're going to pay attention
to the science yes and and i think that
that has been clear
for months in terms of listening to the
discussion about this is that science
has to run the day
and i think that that's what's going to
happen here and i'm very encouraged i'm
encouraged by the other
members of the task force i think that
they really are
outstanding colleagues who can bring a
great deal to the table so
i'm very encouraged mr astro home
we've seen the surge in cases a surge in
hospitalizations in this country
in europe they've had to go back to
lockdowns in some cases
do you see that possibly happening here
again
well i you know first of all if you
interview 50 people they'll give you 75
different definitions of what a lockdown
is
yes and that's one of the challenges we
have
and you know uh i think that there's no
question that our hospitals are about to
be overrun
we're going to see by far the darkest
days of this pandemic
between now and next spring when vaccine
becomes available
uh you know on labor day we are 32 000
cases a day in this country
uh now we're running it in the 120-130
000 cases a day
do not be at all surprised when we hit
200 000 cases a day
why is that happening why is that
happening that the cases are jumping so
quickly and so
in such great number what are we doing
wrong well
you know gail we have a perfect storm
coming together we have
pandemic fatigue people who were
distancing themselves from others for
months who've just decided
you know i kind of done with it even
though the virus isn't done with them we
have a group
we i call pandemic anger up to a third
of the population that believes this
pandemic is still a hoax
and that it's a politically motivated
activity then you pile that all
together with indoor air where basically
we're bringing people indoors much more
we know transmission is enhanced
you know an average house will basically
recirculate its air about once to
uh to two times an hour whereas if
you're in a hospital it's 12 times an
hour
and so that you see virus accumulated in
home so when you have a dinner like a
thanksgiving dinner
it's not un unusual to see transmission
of one person to
five 10 15 people in that home add that
all up together right now
and that's what's happening we just are
not taking this virus seriously
mr osterhom when you say hospitals will
be overrun
i'm particularly concerned because
distribution of the vaccine when it's
available
will come in part through hospitals is
there a worry that the resources of
hospitals
could be tied up with treatment and not
have uh the wherewithal
to actually uh work on the prevention
with vaccination
you know i couldn't have said it any
better you nailed it we're very
concerned about that
you know we need to get vaccine to our
health care workers we know already in
this country that upwards of all
almost 1 500 healthcare workers have
died as a result of covid19
now not all those acquired at work but
many did and so
yes we are very concerned about the
shortage of staff
now just to treat patients than to try
to overlay
the vaccine issue even within the health
care setting itself is going to be a
challenge
so in your view what does this
administration need to do right away
well first of all we have to understand
that operation warp speed has been a
remarkable effort
in terms of bringing vaccines forward i
give them great credit for that
but there still are huge challenges in
how to distribute it remember this
vaccine
has to be kept at minus 94 degrees
fahrenheit
minus 94. we don't have refrigeration
operations like that out here
and there have been very few resources
provided to states and local health
departments
to go beyond the initial planning you
know we
at the public health world out here are
concerned about the planning that
the military is bringing forward as if
by touted by many as the answer
when in fact in many cases we're
concerned it's part of the problem
and so i think that they're going to be
huge disconnects
trying to get the vaccine out into the
communities and then finally we've got
to get these communities convinced they
need it
you know we're seeing data right now
suggesting 50 to 75 percent
particularly in our communities of color
are not at all
willing to take the vaccine because of
concerns for safety we have a lot of
educating to do
before we're going to see people
transfer a vaccine to a vaccination all
right michael ostrom always good to see
you i'm sure we'll be seeing you again
good to see you
thanks a lot i hope so thanks gail all
righty